die impfungen haben begonnen und jetzt
fragt man sich natürlich sind wir da
also wann können wir uns wieder in
knallvollen bars in den armen liegen und
laut singend wann können wir unsere
masten wegschmeißt dann wird alles
wieder normal also wir werden hier kein
datum schätzen weil es von zu vielen
unsicherheiten abhängt wie impfstoff
verfügbar karl logistik usw
aber wir werden der frage nachgehen wie
viele menschen müssen tatsächlich
geimpft sein damit wir wieder ein
normales leben führen können oder wird
es jemals wieder so wie vor der pandemie
pro tag macht es euch gemütlich wir
steigen durch 2020 habe ich im frühjahr
gesagt es müssten 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung immun seien es dann hätten
wir herdenimmunität und dann wäre die
pandemie vorbei allerdings ist das nur
eine grobe nehrung die missverständlich
sein kann also zeit für ein update denn
vieles ist hier nicht so wie es scheint
werden immunität revisited
woher kommen eigentlich diese 60 bis 70
prozent von denen man immer wieder hört
das ist eine vereinfachte überlegung die
etwas mit dem mehrwert zu tun hatte
kurze erinnerung mehrwert oder auch die
produktionszeit gibt an wie viele
personen eine infizierte person im
schnitt an steckt also es kauft zwei der
wert laut lka auf 3,3 bis 3,8 geschätzt
das heißt eine person steckt im schnitt
3,3 bis 3,8 weitere personen genauer
gesagt sprechen wir hier von der basis
die produktionszahl er null gilt wenn
niemand immun ist und wenn keine
maßnahmen unternommen werden um
infektionen zu vermeiden momentan
schaffen wir es ja durch corona
schutzmaßnahmen bei einem mehrwert um
die eins zu sein
das ist dann die effektive reproduktions
zahl die wir einfach nur ernennen wird
wie hängt jetzt der erwert mit unserem
wunsch nach einem normalen leben
zusammen normal im sinne von wir können
alle schutzmaßnahmen wieder aufheben
ohne unsere mitmenschen in gefahr zu
bringen also alles wie vor der pandemie
das ist nur möglich wenn ein ausreichend
großer anteil der bevölkerung immun ist
und zwar so viele dass der
er wehrt auch ohne irgendwelche schutz
und hygienemaßnahmen unter 1 feld warum
angenommen bei corona wäre er 0 gleich
dann wird ein infizierter drei personen
anstecken die jeweils auch wieder drei
und so weiter wenn jetzt aber zwei
drittel der bevölkerung immun sind
dann steckt eine infizierte person nur
noch eine weitere person an also er
effektiv gleich eins dann wird das virus
zwar immer noch weiter gegeben aber die
zahl der infizierten steigt nicht mehr
wenn aber so viele menschen immun sind
das ohne weitere schutzmaßnahmen der
wert unter 1 fällt wenn also eine person
im schnitt weniger ist eine weitere
anstecken kann sinken die
infektionszahlen und irgendwann läuft
sich die pandemie aus und der spuk ist
vorbei so das ist jetzt die formel um
den notwendigen immunität anteil
ausgerechnet wenn man jetzt hier für er
03 einsetzt kommt zwei drittel
beziehungsweise 66,7 prozent raus daher
kommen also diese 60 bis 70 die viele
seit anfang der pandemie im hinterkopf
haben am anfang der pandemie ist man
auch er von einem mehrwert von grob drei
ausgegangen inzwischen sind die
schätzungen aber wie gesagt ein bisschen
höher und das wirkt sich auch auf die
herdenimmunität auch sei er gleich 3,8
wäre die nämlich 74 prozent und ihr habt
bestimmt gehört dass es inzwischen neue
mutationen des gruner virus gibt die
ansteckende sind wie die politische
mutation b als 17 stellen wir uns vor
bei einer ansteckenden variante hätten
wir ein eher 0 von 4,5 dann bräuchten
wir einen herrn die immunität von etwa
78 prozent weil er gleich fünf müssten
schon über 80 prozent der leute immun
sei also je höher er ist desto größer
der anteil der bevölkerung der immun
sein muss um herrn immunität zu
erreichen allerdings ist das alles
ziemlich vereinfacht zb ist der wert nur
ein durchschnittswert es gibt aber noch
die sogenannte dispersion dispersion
heißt bei caro da stecken viele
infizierte niemanden an
dafür stecken ganz wenige infizierte
ganz viel auf einmal ran
stichwort superstar und nur im schnitt
kommt man eben auf 3,3 bis 3,8
ansteckungen pro person entsprechend ist
auch die notwendige herrn immunität ein
durchschnittswert also sagen wir
bräuchten im schnitt 75 prozent herrn
immunität da kann es sein dass in vielen
fällen schon ich sage mal 50 pferden
immunität ausreichen
in anderen fällen nehmen wir die
karnevalssitzung in heinsberg wir
erinnern uns es war eines der ersten
super spreading events in deutschland wo
vielleicht fast alle hätten ihn nun sein
müssen um eine ansteckung zu verhindern
herdenimmunität nach dieser formel ist
also ein vereinfachtes konzept das nicht
pauschal gilt und die geschichte ist
noch lange nicht zu ende
[Musik]
stellen wir uns folgendes szenario vor
irgendwann in ein paar monaten wird in
guter batzen menschen geimpft sein
sagen wir 30 40 50 wie auch immer in
kombination mit unseren schutzmaßnahmen
also kontakte beschränken abstand halten
schnelltest usw kann es passieren dass
die infektionszahlen niedrig sind
vielleicht auch weiter sinken
todeszahlen genauso er wertstabil unter
1 sodass so aussieht als würde die
partie jetzt zu ende auch wenn wir dann
vorschnell denken schilder auf
nimmerwiedersehen und alle maßnahmen
fallen lassen und wieder so leben wollen
wie zuvor könnten wir ein kleines bis
großes lob sie erleben wurzel denn
solange noch keine herdenimmunität
erreicht ist ist der effektive wert
nicht nur der immunität sondern auch den
weiteren schutzmaßnahmen zu verdanken
und wenn wir die aus der gleichung
rausnehmen
steigt der wert wieder und es kann dann
doch noch mal zu einer welle kommen ward
die so einem szenario wenn schon viele
aber noch nicht ausreichend menschen
geimpft sind könnte auch so was wie eine
im faulheit einsetzen weil je mehr
menschen geimpft werden desto normaler
wird unser leben auch schrittweise
werden
und wenn sich dann alles bisschen
normalisiert wenn wieder mehr auf hat
wenn auch die krankenhäuser gerade nicht
überbelastet sind könnte man den
eindruck gewinnen ist jetzt nicht nötig
dass ich mich auch noch impfen lasse
aber sowohl das als auch ein vorstellt
das aufheben der schutzmaßnahmen wäre
ein voreiliger fehlschluss also lasst es
am besten jetzt schon mal in unsere
hinterköpfe kriegen
vorsicht vor einem schein ende der
pandemie und es gibt noch eine
wahrnehmungsfehler die impfungen könnten
vorerst weniger ändern als erwartet die
impfstrategie ist ja diejenigen die das
höchste risiko für schwere bis tödliche
kurve 19 verläufe haben werden zuerst
geimpft sowie bestimmte berufsgruppen
wie gesundheits und pflegeberufe wenn
irgendwann die risikogruppen geimpft
sind kann man schon mal kollektiven
stein vom herzen fallen es ist eine
große erleichterung wir wären dann nicht
nur weniger schwere verläufe und
todesfälle haben
sondern auch die krankenhäuser werden
weniger belastet werden gleichzeitig
sind die menschen aus den risikogruppen
ja nicht gerade diejenigen die bisher
die pandemie getrieben haben gerade am
anfang wären die impfungen nicht
gleichmäßig in der bevölkerung verteilt
sein sondern das wird uns selbst kurz
wie altenheime geben
doch für die restlichen teile der
bevölkerung können fall zahlt und
verbreitung noch genauso sein wie vor da
eben bis also ein spürbarer herdenschutz
für alle anläuft könnte es länger dauern
als viele vielleicht bisher erwarten
nächster punkt die sache mit der
sterilisieren immunität
bisher wissen wir nur dass die impfung
verhindert dass man krank wird ob man
sich trotz impfung aber eher noch
anstecken kann vielleicht ohne dass man
es merkt und das virus auch so wieder an
andere weitergeben kann
das können wir derzeit noch nicht
ausschließen es gibt ja unterschiedlich
antikörper das ist sandra zeck
direktorin des instituts für
medizinische virologie an der uniklinik
frankfurt erkennt sie vom ndr corona
virus update indem sie uns zusammen mit
christian drosten die neueste corona
forschung erklärt es gibt ja
unterschiedlich antikörper die ggg
impfen die antikörper die als erstes
kommen so die erste reaktion des
immunsystems die getätigt kommen danach
und ideal sind typischerweise antikörper
auf unseren schleimhäuten man vor allen
dingen dort findet wo die ansteckung
stattfindet und die können verhindern
dass es zu einer vermehrung des virus
von anfang an kommen das nennt man gar
nicht realisieren will immunität also
immunität heißt man wird nicht mehr
krank sterilisieren de immunität heißt
man kann außerdem andere auch nicht mehr
anstecken das heißt ob eine impfung oder
eine durchgemachte krankheit auch dazu
führen dass man andere nicht mehr
anstecken kann wird derzeit noch
untersucht man muss dazu sagen dass die
meisten im punkt wir zu kennen
schon auch die symptomatische übertragen
reduzieren es gibt auch ausnahmen zum
beispiel bei den meningokokken aber wir
hoffen dass das einfach ähnlich ist wie
bei den anderen stoffen dass es schenken
ziert wird das heißt diese formel für
die herren immunität gilt nur wenn eine
impfung oder eine durchgemachte
krankheit zu einer sterilisieren den
immunität führt ist dieser schutz nicht
komplett gegeben muss die impfquote
höher sein
umher immunität zu erreichen aber warte
mal anderes szenario wenn wir mit
impfungen plus schutzmaßnahmen die
infektion so richtig runter fahren
können so stark dass das virus war sie
niemanden mehr findet die das noch
anstecken könnte könnten wir dieses
arschloch nicht ganz ausrotten
wahrscheinlich nicht und zwar deswegen
nach der pandemie ist vor der andy ich
denke eine ausrottung eine komplette ist
wahrscheinlich das hat mehrere gründe
das eine ist die verbreitung des virus
befinden das ja in ganz vielen regionen
weltweit
und außerdem gibt es schon die
beschreibung vom zweitinfektion also
energie infektion und immer - roubaix
ankommen kann es natürlich auch schwer
das virus auszurotten bisher sieht es
danach aus dass man sich mit zaz kopf 2
innerhalb von kürzerer zeit also
ungefähr einem jahr nochmal infizieren
kann allerdings mit deutlich milderen
symptomen und kürzerer krankheitsdauer
dieselben überlegungen gelten auch für
die immunität nach einer impfung bei der
saas 1 pandemie von 2002 2003 hat man es
geschafft das virus in menschen ganz
auszukommen beim neuen corona virus saß
kopf 2 kann man aber nicht davon
ausgehen dass das genau so funktioniert
das eine ist dass sein dass dort bei der
übertragung asymptomatische und platin
tomatis übertragung nicht so eine große
rolle gespielt hat das heißt das
die übertragen vor allen dingen
stattfand als schon symptome bei den
patienten da waren und wenn man sich
dann bei symptomen isoliert hat dann ist
natürlich eine übertragung
unwahrscheinlich also dass man das viel
leichter konnten kann
ein anderer grund warum saß auch 1 sich
nicht zu verbreitet hat das außerdem
dass das virus nicht so in den oberen
atemwegen sich vermehrt hat wäre es bei
saas koch 2 der fall ist deswegen
natürlich wenn es in der nase sind
zusagen rachen sich viel leichter auf
den gegenüber bereitet als wenn es ganz
tief in der lunge sitzt und das sind
zwei entscheidenden unterschiede
warum saß kurve eins ja sozusagen
ausgerottet wurde aber sag's kraft zwei
weltweit verbreiten konnte man geht
derzeit eher davon aus dass das neue
virus in dem ich wird also hier heimisch
wird also nicht falsch verstehen dass
man es nicht ausrotten kann heißt nicht
dass man nicht kontrollieren
deshalb sprechen sich einige fachleute
derzeit für die langzeitstrategie noko
wird aus nach der man einmal in den
sauren apfel beißt und für paar wochen
wirklich alles richtig runter fährt um
die infektion null zu drücken um dann im
anschluss mit einem fast normalen leben
belohnt zu werden bis die impfung durch
sind die strategie soll ein ausweg sein
aus den ständigen lockt bei uns denn je
niedriger die infektionszahlen desto
leichter lassen sich neue ausbrüche
kontrollieren und bist du leichter lässt
sich auch die freiheit aufrechterhalten
ich will dir aber auch was anderes
hinaus
wenn wir das neue krone virus nicht
ausrotten können bedeutet das im
klartext entweder man wird geimpft oder
man wird sich früher oder später mit
corona infizieren nehmen wir diesen
gedanken mit zu noch ein szenario
stellen wir uns vor wir sind jetzt an
dem punkt an dem alle risikogruppen
geimpft sind
ist das jetzt nicht der punkt an dem wir
vielleicht nicht die pandemie aber
zumindest alle schutzmaßnahmen für
beendet erklären können schließlich ist
das risiko für einen schweren oder
tödlichen verlauf bei nicht
risikogruppen deutlich geringer na ja
auch hier könnte es
trügerischen punkt geben wenn es auf die
ende hinausläuft also wenn das virus
irgendwo hingeht entweder wird man
geimpft oder man wird sich infizieren
dann gibt es hier durchaus ein szenario
in dem das geringere risiko von jungen
erwachsenen wettgemacht wird durch die
schiere anzahl an infektionen
wenn man jetzt zu früh alle
schutzmaßnahmen wieder loswerden würde
und dass wir es einfach so durch
rauschen würde durch die nicht risiko
bevölkerung könnten genauso viele
menschen sterben oder schwere verläufe
haben wir jetzt die intensivstation
könnten sich genauso fühlen nur eben mit
jüngeren stadt mit älteren menschen nur
wenn das virus nie wieder weg geht wird
es dann nie wieder ganz wie vorher wenn
man so will
nein jetzt tatsächlich nicht nur keine
sorge ein indem ich es also hier
heimisches saß kauf 2 ist lange nicht so
schlimm wie es vielleicht erstmal klebt
wie ein tödliches virus zu einer
harmlosen erkältung werden kann selbst
wenn eine impfung oder eine überstandene
krankheit nicht vor infektion also vor
infektion schützt könnte eine infektion
so mild sein wie eine normale erkältung
also ähnlich wie die vier arten von
chroma viren die jetzt schon bei uns
heimisch sind und die zu unseren
saisonalen erkältungsviren zählen wenn
wir jetzt also demnächst entweder alle
geimpft werden oder uns infizieren
danach das virus aber nicht mehr so
gefährlich ist dann haben wir nach der
pandemie und während der ende mai
folgende situation nur wer neu in diese
welt mit dem einheimischen saß kopf zwei
geboren wird kann sich zum ersten mal
damit infizieren den anderen vier
bewohner wären die bei uns umhergehen
steckt man sich in der regel zum ersten
mal zwischen drei und fünf jahren alter
der ersten sitzung des 2009 haben die
menschen offen gelangen findet ja häufig
die ersten hits und ganz verschiedenen
wenn es bei diesem neuen corona virus
ähnlich sein sollte hieße dass nach der
pandemie werden sich vor allem kleine
kinder damit zum ersten mal anstecken
dir ein sehr niedriges risiko für einen
schweren verlauf haben ist diese kinder
dann irgendwann so alt sind dass das
corona virus bzw eine erstinfektion so
gefährlich wäre wie gerade haben sie die
krankheit ja schon längst durchgemacht
und können dann mit einem milden
erkältungs ähnlichen verlauf rechnen
diesem paper wurde modelliert wie die
sterblichkeit von kurt 19 in den jahren
nach der pandemie immer weiter abnehmen
könnte wenn immer weniger ältere
menschen sich zum ersten mal infizieren
sollte sich allerdings herausstellen
dass das gesundheitsrisiko für kinder
doch zu hoch ist dann wird corona zu
einer der vielen krankheiten werden
gegen die man kleinkinder standardmäßig
impft und was mit anderen risikogruppen
es haben ja nicht nur ältere menschen
ein erhöhtes risiko für einen schweren
verlauf
wenn man jetzt mal um sich oben
anschauen wie immun sind zum beispiel
dann können die natürlich ihre vorläufer
haben das sehen wir auch bei anderen
endemischen ja na da kann man sich die
anderen corona werden angucken aber auch
normale renovieren die sind für uns
junge leute mittelalter leute völlig
ungefährlich aber können in den vorher
erkrankten oder immunsupprimierten auch
sehr schwere verläufe dieser zum teil
tödlich verlaufen auslösen und ich denke
das war dann auch ähnlich deswegen ist
es ja wichtig dass um die herum eine
grund lied da es also das viel gekämpft
sind oder schon antikörper haben damit
diese menschen auch geschützt werden
können es ist dasselbe wie bei anderen
impfungen je höher die impfquote in der
bevölkerung desto besser sind die
menschen geschützt die sich aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht impfen
lassen können oder die keinen
ausreichenden impfschutz aufbauen können
okay was heißt das jetzt alles unterm
strich was mit corona leben wirklich
bedeutet
was zu der idee mit corona leben sagen
die oft als pandemie strategie
verstanden oder missverstanden wird nach
dem motto lieber damit abfinden und
anpassen anstatt infektionen weiter zu
vermeiden wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
das ausrotten nicht passieren wird dann
ist die langfristige aussicht ja ein
leben mit corona so nur weil wir nach
der pandemie also nachdem wir durch die
impfungen herren immunität erreicht
haben ganz gut mit diesem virus leben
können ist es bis dahin ja immer noch
gefährlich wenn nicht sogar gefährlicher
mit den neuen mutationen deswegen ist
mit grüner leben meiner ansicht nach
keine strategie für jetzt sondern
einfach nur ein ausblick auf den
endpunkt also auf das worauf es
hinausläuft
die frage ist doch eher wie kommen wir
an es im endpunkt an mit wieviel toten
mit wieviel wirtschaftlichen schäden mit
wie viel psychischer belastung
und hier gilt nach wie vor alle schäden
und belastungen von gesundheit bis
wirtschaft sind umso kleiner hier besser
wir dieses virus unter kontrolle haben
deswegen finde ich mit grüner leben im
sinne von sich damit abfinden jetzt an
diesem punkt der pandemie nicht so
schlau es gab ja in der geschichte der
menschheit noch nie ein virus dass eine
pandemie in diesem globalen ausmaß
ausgelöst hat gegen das wie eine impfung
hatten das dank der info müssen wir eben
nicht diese pandemie überleben oder über
sterben sondern können uns wehren
ich bin jedenfalls super dankbar für all
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler diesen impfstoff möglich
gemacht haben
damit wir uns eben nicht einfach nur mit
diesem virus abgeben müssen und der uns
spritze für spritze ernst langsam aber
stück für stück unserer normalen alltag
wieder zurück
falls dieses video hilfreich fandet
teilt es gerne mit euren freunden oder
eure familie wenn ihr uns unterstützen
möchte das auch gerne einen like da
ansonsten für alle freunde der sonne
auch alle die mir geschrieben haben
vielen dank dafür mir geht es gut mir
ging es auch gut ich war in den letzten
wochen bzw
monaten sitzt schon im tunnel weil ich
ein buch schreiben musste bzw ist fertig
kriegen musste aber wir machen alles
wieder gut
wir haben ziemlich vorgenommen in den
nächsten monaten alle meine erfolge
jetzt ausgefallen sind auch wieder
nachzuholen das heißt wir werden uns
nicht zwingend alle zwei wochen sehen
sondern manchmal auch jede woche ich
freue mich auf jeden fall sehr drauf wir
sehen uns dann vielleicht schon nächste
woche mal schauen
allerspätestens in zwei wochen bis dahin
bleibt sicher